good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 17:70 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures SCP 1770 is to be held in a
standard reinforced humanoid containment
chamber in sight nineteen's maximum
security wing while the subject has been
docile during its containment due to its
violent history two armed guards are to
be posted at the entrance to the
subjects chamber at all times and the
inside of the chamber is to be under
constant surveillance
due to SCP 1770s resistance to standard
ballistic ammunition and its
vulnerability to corrosive materials the
guards are to be armed with corrosive
agents all personnel handling a CP 1770
are to wear full-body hazmat suits not
allowing any skin contact with SCP 17:70
description SCP 17:70 is an inanimate
mass of an indeterminate number of steel
chains shaped like an average-sized
humanoid the subject appears to be in
possession of human level intelligence
though it does not seem to be in full
control of its mental faculties SCP 1770
is capable of ambulation and speech
though it will rarely initiate
conversation and if left to its own
devices will not move the only thing
capable of temporarily alleviating SCP
1770s apathy are works of art depicting
nature scenes abstractions or inanimate
objects pieces depicting humans will
cause it to regress further into apathy
and will often result in it curling into
the corner of its self for several days
and becoming completely unresponsive
prior to its containment SCP 1770s
showed the ability to remove chains from
its body and attach them to human beings
a process which does not appear to
reduce SCP 1770s mass or the total
number of chains composing a CP 1770s
body the conversion process leads to the
death of the victim in one of its early
stages even if the chains are removed
and gives SCP 17:70 complete control
over the bodies of its victims
eventually turning them into instances
of scp-1730
by one end of the chain which can extend
up to 50 metres from a CP 1770 the
stages of the transformation are as
follows
stage 1 SCP 1770 attacks a victim
pulling him or her using chains removed
from its body wrapping them around the
victims limbs and throat the victim
usually expires due to asphyxiation
during this stage the victims body's
physical strength increases to about 3
times that of an average human of the
victim's sex age and weight stage 2 SCP
1770 then inserts its chains into the
victim's body usually penetrating the
skin at various points including the
eyes the nose and the mouth if the
victim survived the previous stage of
the process they will expire due to the
massive trauma inflicted here the
victims senses increase in efficiency
despite the destruction of various
sensory organs by SCP 1770s chains SCP
1770 has been known to use victims in
this stage of the transformation as a
means to restrain new victims or delay
foundation personnel attempting to
contain it
Stage three SCP 17:70 begins replacing
the victims flesh with chains taken from
its own body as CP 1770 will begin to
shape the amalgamation of flesh and
chains into a new shape
the shape is usually humanoid but on
rare occasions the chains will instead
form into a complicated series of knots
SCP 1770 shows a powerful protective
urge towards the knot formations and
will devote all resources available to
defend them from harm including risking
its own body stage form SCP 1770
completely replaces all of the victims
flesh thereby completing the
transformation process and making the
victim into an instance of scp-1732 SCP
1770 and continued to serve it but not
like instances disconnect and vanish
upon completion notably contact with SCP
1770s chains does not cause any of the
above symptoms unless the subject
initiates the conversion process by
removing chains from its body SCP 1770s
current disposition is docile but prior
to its containment it exhibited extreme
aggression towards humans and attempted
to convert them into instances of
scp-778 1 whenever possible
this behavior led to it to actively seek
human population centers though it chose
only such places which allowed it to act
covertly from information gathered in
conversations with SCP 1770 and
observations of field agents involved in
its capture it has been deduced that the
process of converting humans served as a
sort of artistic outlet for SCP 17:70
and that it was compelled to perform it
possibly by an external force see
interview long since its containment the
subject showed no signs of this
compulsion and all attempts at
conversion on its part ceased even when
granted a helpless subject for the
process
addendum 1770 the following our
interviews made with SCP 1770 during
various stages of its containment
interview log 1771 interviewer dr.
interviewed SCP 1774 word this interview
was made immediately following SCP 1770s
capture at this stage no artistic
stimulus was required playing
[Music]
interview log 1775 interviewer dr.
interviewed as CP 1774 word this
interview with s CP 1770 was made in one
of its more lucid moments when it was
fairly responsive and coherent subject
was shown a copy of Monet's water lilies
as a stimulus
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
closing statement it appears SCP 17:70
believes it has lost its ability to bind
with humans and indeed it's motivation
to do so nevertheless considering the
potential risks it still holds current
security measures are to be maintained
recommending further investigation of
the force SCP 17:70 mentioned
[Music]
okay I feel like I have to apologize my
voice is very tired at the moment I
think I'm sick or rundown or something
even more so than usual so I can only
apologize anyway I think that about does
it for today thank you all for listening
if indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed
good bye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Boober MIT dread the reclusive
extrovert GM's Sabha arbiter soul
Darius Tom Justin day Oh philia gray
Durham Curie kuma and jayvo Jack
Jonathan Augusto Joseph Lewis su Qing
modding and dr. Proctor thank you all so
much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the VOC thank you
[Music]
you